Many Korean firms have moved their factories to China...
...expecting to receive a large labor cost-savings.
And some of those same Korean firms wish to achieve similar cost-savings with their factories here...
...by bringing workers from China.
Chinese workers believe if they go to Korea,...
...they'll earn about 10 times more than in China.
They also think it is best to be recruited by their own company...
...because it costs less than other ways of coming to Korea to work.
However, there is one big problem with this scenario.
After arriving, they are naturally quite angry upon finding out that...
...Korea has different pay scales for:
One, undocumented (illegal) workers
Two, migrant workers registered as trainees...
...by the Korea Federation of Small and Medium Businesses
Three, trainees from overseas invested companies.
Workers in the last group were in the worst situation. Why?
Workers who are paid by the original factory abroad...
...can be paid the same wage as the workers in China.
This allows Korean companies to use a legal loophole to truly exploit migrant labor.
Some Korean factories employ Korean workers, normal migrant workers,...
...and migrant workers transferred from overseas factories...
...who perform the same job,..
...work the same hours under the same roof all on different pay scales.